nos dicen que fx es igual a 1 entre la
raíz de x + 1 y lo que queremos
encontrar en esta ocasión es el
polinomio de marketing de segundo grado
de efe y como siempre pausa en este
vídeo y vea si pueden encontrarlo vienen
primero vamos a recordar que es un
polinomio de mclaren un polinomio de
mack loring es simplemente un polinomio
de taylor centrado en 0 en x igual a
cero así que la forma de ese polinomio
de mclaren de segundo grado ojo nosotros
sólo tenemos que encontrar esta
expansión de mclaren hasta el segundo
término así que este se va a ver así
pd x ojo uso la [ __ ] el polinomio va a
ser igual a efe de 0 más y bueno pues de
haber escrito
efe de 0 x x elevado a la cero pero ves
o simplemente efe de cero
efe de 0 + f prima de 0 esto por x
más efe prima de 0 esto dividido entre 2
bueno tal vez no podrá escribir como 2
factorial pero en realidad solamente 2
podremos ver este como dividido entre 1
factorial pero simplemente 1 y está
dividido entre 0 factorial que también
es simplemente 1 entonces no voy a
escribir eso y nos quedaría la segunda
derivada evaluada en 0 dividida entre 2
y multiplicada por x cuadrada ahora bien
si quisiéramos un grado mayor podríamos
continuar pero recuerden sólo nos están
pidiendo para el segundo grado así que
esta es la forma que vamos a necesitar
vamos a tener estos tres términos así
que veamos si podemos evaluar la función
y sus derivadas en cero bien empecemos
con efe de cero
efe de cero va a ser igual a uno entre
la raíz de 01 y para eso es lo mismo que
1 entre la raíz de 1 la raíz principal
lo cual me va a dar simplemente 1
entonces
efe de 0 es igual a 1 y ahora vamos a
encontrar la f prima de x
y luego vamos a evaluar esa primera
derivada en cero
ahora bien voy a escribir por acá a fx
pero de otra manera
fx es lo mismo que x + 1 esto elevado a
la menos un médium y si estamos pensando
en la primera derivada de f
bien aquí puedo usar la regla de la
cadena voy a hacer la derivada de x + 1
con respecto a x lo cual es simplemente
1 por lo tanto no lo voy a poner y luego
sacamos la derivada de toda esta
expresión completa con respecto a x + 1
y ahí voy a usar la regla de las
potencias esto va a ser lo mismo que me
agarró el exponente lo bajo y me quedan
menos un médium por x más 1 elevado a la
anp y disminuyó en 1 el exponente
entonces me quedan menos 3 medios
entonces la primera derivada de evaluada
en cero
es simplemente menos un medio porque
esto me quedaría
0 0 1 lo cual es simplemente 1 y 1
elevado la menos 3 medios eso va a
seguir siendo igual a 1 así que f prima
de 0 es igual a menos 1
entonces nuestro segundo término este de
aquí es menos un medio
ahora vamos a encontrar la segunda
derivada entonces fbi prima de x va a
ser igual y bueno me voy a trabajarla de
la misma manera la derivada de x + 1 con
respecto a x es simplemente 1 así que no
lo voy a poner lo tenemos que
multiplicar por 1 y después solo tengo
que sacar la derivada de menos un médium
que multiplican a x más uno elevado al
menos tres medios con respecto a x más
uno entonces tomó el exponente que es
menos tres medios y lo llevó hacia el
frente y me quedarían menos tres medios
por menos un medio bueno esto es lo
mismo que tres cuartos
entonces me queda tres cuartos que
multiplican a x más uno elevado a lahm y
vuelvo a disminuir en uno el exponente o
en dos medios entonces va a ser elevado
al menos cinco medios y ahora si
pensamos en fbi prima de cero
bueno en x igual a cero obtenemos que
esto es un elevado al menos cinco medios
lo cual es simplemente uno por tres
cuartos de estrés
entonces efe mi prima de 0 es igual a
tres cuartos así que el numerador de
nuestro tercer término es tres cuartos y
a esto hay que dividirla entre dos
entonces me quedaría igual a tres
octavos
ahora si nuestro polinomio de mclaren de
segundo grado que nosotros buscábamos es
el siguiente
pd x es igual y voy a usar sus
respectivos colores me quedaría 1 y
después tengo menos un medio por x menos
un médium x más tres octavos de x
cuadrada y hemos terminado ahí lo tienen
tenemos nuestro polinomio de mclaren de
segundo grado de efe que puede ser usado
para proporcionar una aproximación para
nuestra función especialmente si nuestra
x es cercana a 0